متى
يعود سفر العمل إلى طبيعته أم أنه سيتم
تعريفه على أنه أمر طبيعي جديد ربما يكون
أقل بمقدار 25 أو 30 مما كنت عليه قبل
الجائحة ،
قد يقول الثاني إن العكس
هو ما حدث نتيجة للإغلاق
كنتيجة لاضطرارك للانخراط
في الشبكات التي تراها
سواء كان فريق Zoom أو أيًا كان ما
رأيته في منتصف التسعينيات
عندما قمنا برقمنة الاقتصاد العالمي
وجاءت كل هذه الأدوات لتسويق
العالم الرقمي  حكم عصر
المعلومات
وقال الجميع أنك تعرف
ما سيحدث لن نسافر حقًا
بعد الآن لن نرغب في
القيام بذلك
وفي الواقع يمكننا فعل الكثير مما
أردنا القيام به
على العكس  حدث
بين عامي 1995 و 2015 2018
، نما الطلب على السفر بغرض العمل بشكل
كبير
مع عودتنا إلى طبيعتنا حيث
تم تعزيز الاقتصاد
مع بدء تدفق الأموال مرة أخرى إلى
الأعمال التجارية ،
وسوف تنسى كل ذلك كما هو الحال دائمًا
هل سنبدأ في
رؤية ارتداد رحلات العمل مرة أخرى
وسنرى أنه ينمو
ولن يتباطأ ، فأنت تعلم أن لديك
خمسة مليارات دولار تأرجح من
الربحية إلى الخسارة في
الربع الأخير ،
هل يمكنك الوصول إلى الربحية في
النصف الأول من عام 2022  بصفتي ناقل ،
أعتقد أننا سنبدأ في رؤية
عودة سريعة إلى الإيجابية النقدية
خلال 21
مرة أخرى في النصف الخلفي ، أود أن أقول إنه في
السنة المالية 22
23 ، حيث سترى شركة الطيران
تعود إلى الربحية
أم  وتوليد النقد
الذي يحتاجه
للقيام بكل ما لديه أو الوفاء بالالتزامات
التي لديه
، ويمكننا بعد ذلك متابعة خططنا
لتجديد الأسطول
لتوسيع شبكة الشبكة مع بعض
الطائرات الجديدة
والأدوات التي نحتاجها لبدء
فتح جديد  النقاط
التي ستحدث في 22 23 24 ،
حسنًا ، قد أكون خارج المنزل لمدة ستة أشهر
ولكن في الماضي ، حصلنا عليها بشكل عام
عندما نجري
تقييمًا لما قد يحدث
، وفي النهاية
تخطط لذلك عليك  من الخاص بك
le الشركة في تلك
الخطة وآمل أن تكون جيدة كما
أعتقد أنها ستكون